problem number six let F be defined by f
of X is equal to and we have two cases
when X is less than or equal to 0 F is 1
minus 2 sine of X when x is greater than
0 F is e to the negative 4x show that F
is continuous at x equals 0 so for
something to be continuous at x equals 0
let's think about what has to happen so
if I have a function here so that is my
x-axis and let's say this is my this is
my y-axis and we care about what happens
at x equals 0 so x equals 0 there and
let's say that this is our function
let's say that this is our function so
maybe our function may be look something
like this I don't know what well this
one in particular probably looks
something like this this one in
particular this one in particular might
look who knows and then it might look
something like that and the particulars
aren't that important we just have to
think about what they're asking in order
for it to be continuous here the limit
as we approach as we approach from the
left the limit as we approach from the
left so the limit as we approach 0 from
the left should be equal to the value of
the function at 0 so this should so the
limit of f of X should be equal to f of
0 which should be equal to the limit as
we approach from the right which should
be equal to the limit as we approach 0
from the right so that should be equal
to the limit as X approaches 0 from the
right of f of X and the reason why this
matters is if this if this wasn't the
case if F of 0 wasn't the same as the
limit then we might have a gap right
over there so you could have a you could
have limits so you could have a
situation like this where you have a gap
right over there and then it looks
something like that so the two limits
from the left and the right both exist
and the limit at that point would exist
but if the function itself does not
equal that value there if it equals
something else then the function would
not be continuous so that's why the
limit has to be equal to the value of
the function in order for it to be
continuous so let's think about whether
all of these things equal each other
first so first of all let's just think
about the value of the function there
so remember we're doing Part A f of 0 is
equal to we're going to use this first
case because that's the case for X is
less than or equal to 0 so f of 0 is
going to be equal to 1 minus 2 sine I
didn't write the two - sine of 0 - sine
of 0 well sine of not theta sine of 0 is
0 2 times 0 0 so this whole thing is 0 1
minus 0 is 1 fair enough
now let's think about the limit now
let's think about the limit as X
approaches 0 from the left hand side so
as as we approach 0 from the left hand
side of f of X so as we approach 0 from
the left hand side we're dealing with
values of X that are less than 0 so once
again we're dealing with this first case
up here so this is the limit as X
approaches 0 from the left hand side of
1 minus 2 sine of X now sine of X is
continuous it's a continuous function so
this is going to be the same thing as 1
minus 2 sine of 0 which we've already
figured out which is exactly equal to 1
so this is equal to 1 so the value of
the limit as we approach from the left
is the same as the value of the function
now let's do it front as we approach
from the right as we approach from
values of X greater than 0 so let's
think about the limit as we approach 0
from the right of f of X so here we're
dealing with values of X that are larger
than 0 so we're dealing with this case
right over here
so that's going to be the limit as X
approaches 0 from the right of e to the
negative 4x and for the exes that we
care about or actually in general this
is a continuous function this is a
continuous function so it's this is
going to be the same thing as e to the
negative 4 times 0 which is just e to
the 0 which is just 1 so this once again
is equal to 1 so the function is equal
to 1 at that point the limit as we
approach from the left is equal to 1 and
the limit as we approach from the right
is equal to 1 so the function is
continuous there